hay varios temas que son bastante
complicados los los grupos de trabajo
han propuesto en los días previos a la
Cumbre una precumbre que se realizó el
tres al cinco de diciembre que se pueda
trabajar con el 30% de las áreas
terrestres y las áreas marinas para que
estén protegidas que haya un avance
continuo en ese porcentaje de tierras y
y mares océanos protegidos de aquí hasta
2030 hasta llegar al 30% es lo que ellos
han llamado el 30 por 30 sin embargo
este punto no se logró incluir en la
agenda inicial no llegaron a ese punto y
en los próximos días se espera que se
sea uno de los puntos que se vaya a
tocar otro tema álgido es el tema del
financiamiento ya que se tiene la meta
de que hayan dos billones de dólares al
año invertidos en programas para poder
ayudar a la recuperación de la
biodiversidad de aquí hasta el año 2030
y este tema también ha sido bastante
intenso porque este fondo Todavía no se
ha logrado ayer el presidente Justin el
Primer Ministro canadiense anunció que
va a aportar 350 millones de dólares a
este fondo el gobierno chino también ha
hecho varios avances previamente a este
fondo